this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
Apple just surprised everyone with the
new 20/20 MacBook Air and for the first
time ever it's packing a quad-core
processor which makes choosing between
the MacBook Air and the MacBook Pro even
more difficult so in this video I'll
touch on that topic as well as talk
about five mistakes you should avoid
when ordering your 20/20 MacBook Air
first I want to mention some of the
great changes we're getting with this
new model like the new 10 gen Intel
processors which are much more efficient
than before and they also include brand
new Intel iris plus graphics that are up
to 80 percent faster than the previous
model we now get the new updated magic
keyboard a 20% larger trackpad new
speakers with two times more bass and
25% more volume finally Bluetooth five
and more even though it still gets up to
16 gigs of ram it's now much faster 37
33 megahertz Ram compared to the old 21
33 megahertz Ram on the previous model
the base storage is now 256 gigs finally
because 128 was seriously limiting you
can now get up to a crazy 2 terabytes of
storage which seems a little bit
overkill for a MacBook Air but it's nice
to have that option so with that let's
get into the 5 mistakes you should avoid
when ordering your 20/20 macbook air let
me tell you about a sponsor Squarespace
if you've been thinking about making
your own website
Squarespace is seriously the best way to
go I built an engaging website from my
wife's cleaning business with literally
no web making experience you just choose
a template customize blocks of text and
images and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable and it's
been running flawlessly for almost two
years bringing in new clients thanks to
his built-in SEO tools first off for a
long time the biggest downside of the
air has been the dual core processor so
I would honestly recommend that no one
buy the dual core absolutely spend the
extra hundred dollars on the i5 quad
core processor because it's going to
greatly improve performance not only
that but there's a chance that the
integrated graphics on the i-5 is faster
than on the i3 as
well but we won't know that until we get
our hands on the new MacBook Air which
we've already ordered and should be
getting soon so make sure you're
subscribed so you don't miss out on that
video for the second mistake don't buy
the best processor if you don't
absolutely need it for most people the
i7 isn't worth it since it's an extra
$150 over the i-5 and it likely won't
add that much performance unless it
comes with a faster graphics chip the
i-5 is already a quad-core and it's
going to be able to handle a lot of
programs very well and it'll handle
regular 4k video editing just fine now
if you absolutely want the most
performance then buy the i7 but be sure
not to make the third mistake this year
there is absolutely no benefit to
choosing the higher-end $1,300 model
first and then upgrading to the i7
processor every upgrade comes out to
exactly the same price so it actually
makes sense to start with a $1000 model
and configure exactly what you want this
way you can save $200 on the storage
upgrade if 256 gigs is enough for you
for the fourth mistake don't buy too
much storage if you don't need it some
people think they need the massive two
terabytes of storage but that adds an
extra $800 to the bill and to be honest
most people will be completely fine with
512 gigs or maybe one terabyte at the
maximum so that extra savings allows you
to invest the difference into the 16
gigabyte of RAM upgrade for example but
be careful not to make our fifth mistake
if you're not trying to work with
professional apps like programming using
Xcode video editing with Final Cut Pro
10 photo editing or music production
with Logic Pro 10 you most likely don't
need 16 gigs of RAM Apple has been doing
an incredible job with the efficiency of
apps and RAM management so even if you
have quite a few tabs open you should
most likely be fine with 8 gigs of ram
now on the other hand if you do a ton of
multitasking then I would definitely
consider the 16 gigabyte RAM upgrade now
before we get into recommending which
2020 MacBook Air upgrades we recommend
for each use case I want to mention why
I think this is a much better buy than
the base 13 inch MacBook Pro first off
the cheapest MacBook Pro model with 256
gigabytes
storage costs $1,500 compared to a
thousand dollars on the macbook air and
$1,100 for the i-5 quad-core model
that's a massive savings secondly the
air gets a bunch of new features like
the new magic keyboard which is
incredibly important to a lot of people
and other features like new updated
speakers better microphones and the 10
gen quad-core processor which may not be
as fast but it'll definitely get close
and the new Intel irisbus graphics will
most likely be faster than the graphics
on the 13-inch pro however there is
still a good reason to buy the 13-inch
pro and that's the better display with
p3 wide color gamut for serious photo
editors but for everyone else looking
for a macbook around the 1,000 to $1,500
price range the new 13-inch MacBook Air
is definitely the better buy now let's
get into which upgrades we recommend for
each use case if you're just trying to
get a MacBook as cheap as possible
you're probably gonna be happy with the
base dual-core model but remember that
there are some incredible deals on
renewed 2019 models on Amazon like this
one for only seven hundred and seventy
nine dollars we'll post a link down
below if you're interested for anyone
who's working with creative programs
like Microsoft Office apps programming
photo editing video editing or other
apps I would definitely recommend
upgrading to the i-5 quad-core processor
for anyone doing photo editing
programming a lot of 4k video editing or
a ton of multitasking then I would
definitely recommend the 16 gigabyte RAM
upgrade now if you really really take
your work seriously and you want the
absolute best performance just go for
the i7 quad core processor even though
you might not see the full $150
difference in performance and finally
finishing off of the storage I honestly
think 256 gigs will be enough for a lot
of basic users who just want to browse
the web stream videos like Netflix and
use web-based apps those doing work on
their macbook should definitely consider
getting 512 gigs of storage and anything
beyond that is purely up to you just be
sure to spend your money wisely if this
video helps you learn something new tap
the like button and click the circle
above so you don't miss out on our
compare
some videos coming soon and feel free to
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]